welcome to this video yeah a new and in
this case in the last video covering my
games from the european club cab the
tablet 7 final round of the tournament
yeah my team was playing a team from
lithuania and i was playing um guy
called details streamer videos probably
butchering up the pronunciation as usual
yeah and a junior player turned out born
in nineteen ninety eight which feels
kind of bizarre to me that he was born
at a time when I don't know when I was
already at the same minus rating than
ever met that help now so okay 15 16
year-old player and he's rated 2375
during the art 70 furniture during them
the game when it was played so a very
promising junior player here from
Lithuania my prep I consisted of her
finding out that he mostly plays defined
knows what he's doing so I was some
quickly looking at some lines from my
book project nim zobo go and well I sat
down sitting at the board and mm-hmm and
he's playing whoops g3 so that's it with
preparation yeah okay so we just play a
game without any theoretical discussion
in a way the d5 Bishop g2 okay yeah here
I had I was thinking for a moment what
what his idea might be um what I do and
I think it's something that sometimes
pays off I also when I prepare for an
opponent and look at let's say a player
we like here with black I'm looking of
course and what what he's doing with
white but i also have a quick look what
is playing with black just to get an
impression and it
occur to me that this guy is playing the
the dutch leningrad against d4 so I was
thinking maybe with this move order he
wants to do something like this if I go
see six now but many players at doing
maybe he wants to play a for all of a
sudden and then he has tricked me into
sort of the Leningrad reversed and I
have played the knurl ez pawn to c6 hmm
if nothing terrible i mean this is
something that black can play but at
least my choice is somewhat somewhat
limited so I thought for a moment and I
went he five just grabbing the center I
didn't go we have here oops not that he
five here because then he has see formed
and we all of the Sun have a in English
which I don't know with black young I
don't really know that opening so this
is why I went d5 first and only here I
went he five I was thinking that f4 here
this this thing with the landing a drug
Leningrad Dutch reversed I was already
here considering on with one like g3d
five I was thinking that this maybe is
not a good idea due to age five this
this kind of thing looks looks very
dangerous I was only thinking about this
over the board but it looks very
dangerous so okay to cut this short he
went Bishop g2 I Wendy five so there is
no reversed Dutch today he played d3
which I welcomed yeah now we get a
reversed pilk pets um yeah I was a bit
more concerned about c4 I'm not totally
sure what i do then I mean
I mean okay it's not like an out of
ideas but here black has some
possibilities can cake yeah he can play
c6 I can't play d4 i know i'm not quite
sure what I would have done but okay he
didn't do that he went as mentioned he
went d3 okay yeah and against this kind
of reversed pig I always played the
setup Knight to c6 at a free g6 yeah I I
like this the setup castles Bishop g7 92
nite g7 C three castles fo yeah very
standard type of setup it's also like a
Kings Indian attack yeah for white and
black has put up his pieces in that that
fashion before you and then I went a
five to prevent any be for business yeah
what is blacks idea his ideas to to set
up a very solid central formation like
h6 Bishop be 627 rook da droopy eight
like they are put everything in the
center and just ask right okay what
exactly is your plan in this position
like it's very much well centralized and
there's no bad pieces I always think
that this kind of setup is very very
comfortable to play at least in terms of
equality um yeah he played a for now
yeah maybe stopping my pawn and possibly
fighting for the c-4 square yeah in case
of this pawn on d5 moving like taking or
advancing he will get the square for the
night on c4 I went age six hard to do
without this move I want to play Bishop
e-cigs at some point Quincy to there
should be six and now he captured on d5
yeah interesting interesting moment
white is giving up the center here for
from the moment but he wants some
counter players and played against the
e5 pawn yeah okay I captured a 95 was
also possible but Bishop takes is an
interesting choice I like the move the
idea was after rookie one Queen D 794 I
had originally planned the movie for him
yeah at first it looks it looks rather
nice yeah if white takes oops he
blunders a piece but then when I was
sitting there right at the board I was
all of a son recognizing that white has
a good a good continuation here
surprisingly surprisingly good
continuation he can play night ft to the
point is that what I was first thinking
after this capture um why does not force
to take with the porn because after f5 I
really have a nice structure I have this
idea night coming to d3 and all in all I
have a nice centralized position he's
not forced to do that he can play Knight
takes e4 and this is quite strong pawn
takes d3 and queen bee three and if you
look at this position you will see that
white has a tremendous compensation for
the poor it is quite apparent after
while maybe if you look at it white now
has strong pieces all around a great
bishop this bishop will come to an
active square I b7 hangs and he just
plants like Bishop f4 III yeah rook to
d1 and then picking up the porn I
cannot really support the pawn this
position is excellent for white I'm glad
that I has spotted that because c4 was
Eva was my original plan but okay it's
not a big problem my center is well
supported anyway um at first I thought
after I spotted this oky and not a big
deal I just take I just takes e4 why not
and play this position not bad yeah this
is not a bad position but then I saw
another possibility and this this serve
in interviewed me I went with rook fe8
after after this little Nazi forms yeah
is this a blunder it looks like and
blundering the e5 pawn now it's not a
blunder but it's an interesting pawn
sacrifice um I actually believe that he
should have taken it he should have
taken the born let's look at it what's
happening is is rather force if white
takes and it's not really a huge
difference how he takes yeah let's let's
say with this I capture takes take take
yeah and here we come to the first
interesting moment my idea was that now
I have two possibilities and I wasn't
sure what's better after Bishop tg-2
King takes i have this check King g1 and
night f5 this looks attractive the whole
thing is based on the fact of course
that white is very much not developed
not moved not moved and a week backrack
yeah plus there is 94 white however has
a safe here the most look to e4 quite
I'm not sure surprisingly if you
this holds the fort Black now has no
great continuation yeah it is really a
bit surprising but it is it is really
their case it looks it looks really bad
at first but I have no I have nothing
great in this position why it seems to
be in trouble but there is nothing
nothing apparent if for example um I
play 94 which looks yeah fancy you just
place a quickie one and there's nothing
happening it's quite quite quite funny
it's a it's weird so this is not enough
but my second idea as it seems better 96
sorry em night f-550 95 this is this is
also interesting the idea is quite
similar we had we attack the rook here
and white cannot take because there is
this happening yeah and here I have a
substantial compensation rook e8 rupee
aid Queen D 1 it's necessary really yeah
because there was this thread only one
takes takes and now a move like c5 that
should give black enough compensation
it's not more than that but it is
compensation my original intention
really was to go for this line I didn't
see that rookie for such a strong
defense but the other line it seems with
them that i just showed this one with
this end position and seems to be okay
for like giving giving me a enough
compensation but this is what he
probably should have done his
continuation really yeah it did not did
not help him a lot
he went Bishop e3 and in this position I
already anticipated the end of the game
i saw the how I could win the game and
and it was really funny that that it
happened okay I'm not spoiling too much
I think I now went night f5 just
attacking this this bishop may be taking
it he went rook t1 and in this position
it was it was clear to me what is what
his plan was he wanted to play look T 1
and he wanted to probably put the bishop
on c1 yeah you don't really want to like
to take the bishop and my ration there
was a quite I could have taken it of
course yeah I mean I went when when I
went to f5 and here i can't take now but
I was thinking when I go rook d8 he will
probably play Bishop see one this might
be the idea that he that he was having
he wants to preserve this bishop and
yeah the funny thing is Bishop see one
would lose the game straight away like
immediately I'm not showing you why
because it's the same thing in the game
he went to see Five like p62 went to a
three yeah and here if you want a small
small tactical puzzle you can look at
this black to play and win might see it
in the the move mystère yeah black to
play it when the winner is Bishop f3
counterintuitive but if it wins the game
why not takes oops and 94 funny take
stakes and now we have a huge fork Queen
and bishop yeah ands not that the bishop
one of three Falls with check and it's
taking an exchange with it he went to
Queens III I took
next one and after this he resigned yeah
why does an exchange down a pawn down
and he will lose even more material this
and this so this was the final game
winner after 22 moves my opponent simply
had an off day he did not see this this
needs little tactical this technical
trick it was quite funny when he played
Bishop c5 it was clear to me that when I
play b6 his idea is to play Bishop e3
and no one plays Bishop c5 and after b6
goes back but I was thinking if I now
take like 10 minutes and play b6 he will
might he might spot it it's even might
see it so I paid p6 basically
immediately and yeah he he went to a
three and then I could could win the
game they're funny yeah okay if he for
some reason it was spotted it yeah and
went to e3 back then black quite clearly
has a good position here I'm perfectly
centralized um I'm not sure what what I
would have done i'm pretty sure that i
wouldn't have played the move that the
computer Houdini here just suggested i
was thinking that if everything else
fails I mean I was it was positive that
this is the best what something like
that is at least good for black I mean
not like brilliant but it's a good
structure this was my my my if
everything else fails plan the computer
points out a really nice really nice
move from night to be eight funny yeah
very funny move and it turns out that
this is this is quite quite nice the ad
is to play this move Queen to c6 all of
a sudden building up some pressure on
the long diagonal it's not easy to
counter this move why turn white already
a sense
trouble here now he needs to do some
fairly unnatural moves to to make sure
that he count justice this pressure this
is pressure of course I mean Bishop c5
b6 Bishop e3 SS pretty is pretty dump
but maybe if he recognizes that Bishop a
three leads to leads to a disaster he
should you should still go back to e3 of
course yeah i was a bit a bit lucky if
you want in this game that that i want
that that quickly i really had an off
day I mean not lucky in the sense that I
was in danger but it was a very easy win
let's say that I didn't expect at all to
happen at least not that then not that
quickly always thankful on in a final
round of a tough tournament that you
don't have to play like a six hour seven
hour marathon game it's happened in the
final round by the way when they were
already handing out the the the the
winners cup and and everything the
Champions Cup there were suits some guy
playing some guys was to playing and in
the hole but it was already clear word
won the championship yeah okay I hope
you enjoy to discourage five games of my
tournament en the european club cap I
will do those kind of this coverage of
my own games more often at least if the
games are interesting I have played two
more games and then recent weeks like
two or three weeks in the leak chest at
R also interesting and I would cover
those in the next the next couple of
days thanks for watching